[Música]
ya lo mencionado hoy en directo ahora
vamos a la capital estadounidense para
hablar de dos temas el primero es el
revés del expresidente Donald Trump al
que la Corte Suprema le ordenó que
publique sus declaraciones de impuestos
por lo que tendrá que entregarlas al
comité de la cámara de representantes
que investiga una posible evasión fiscal
y la segunda es el título 42 con el que
se ha deportado alrededor de 2,4
millones de inmigrantes irregulares la
Casa Blanca implementa planes para su
derogación a esta hora conectamos con
Cristóbal Vázquez corresponsal de
Francia 24 Cristóbal empecemos con la
decisión sobre las declaraciones de
impuestos para Donald Trump Qué
implicaciones tiene para el ex
mandatario ya precandidato presidencial
concretamente lo que ocurrió fue que la
Corte Suprema de Justicia máximo órgano
judicial de este país y que además tiene
mayoría conservadora después de que
Donald Trump precisamente haya nombrado
a tres magistrados de corte conservador
pues le negó el recurso de emergencia
que los abogados de Donald Trump estaban
buscando para que Donald Trump no
tuviera que presentarle su declaración
de impuestos a este comité de finanzas
de la cámara de representantes que en
este momento es de mayoría demócrata
entonces así las cosas Pues en la
autoridad de impuestos de Estados Unidos
va a tener que entregar estos documentos
estas declaraciones de renta del ex
presidente Donald Trump en los últimos
años que recordemos el ex presidente
había tratado de tapar desde el 2016
cuando siendo candidato se le pidió que
la publicara Pero él de muchas maneras y
a través de muchas
formas y vías legales trató de esconder
Pues ahora ya legalmente
opción lo demócratas de ver esto lo que
pasa es que el 3 de enero cambia de mano
la cámara de representantes y los
republicanos se espera que pues
suspendan esta petición para que se
publique esta información financiera del
ex presidente Bueno pues Hablamos ahora
del título 42 que debe ser suspendido en
alrededor de un mes
exactamente concretamente el 21 de
diciembre pero recordemos que la
administración de yobidy donde había
pedido al departamento de Justicia que
por favor aplazar a cinco semanas
mientras se hacía el acople mientras se
construían y se Pues preparaban los
albergues de cara una eventual o la
migratoria que venga después de levantar
esta medida que ya el centro de control
y prevención de enfermedades de Estados
Unidos Pues dijo que no era necesaria
para controlar la pandemia recordemos
que el título subtítulo 42 lo que hacía
era darle el argumento a las autoridades
migratorias y fronterizas de expulsar a
los migrantes con el el argumento de
proteger al país por el covid ya no es
necesario para controlar la pandemia
pero lo que se supo es que 15 estados
que son administrados por republicanos
quieren mantener el título 42 incluso
después de que se venza el término para
este para para suspender esta medida que
es el 21 de diciembre